der livestream von heute plus herzlich
willkommen droht uns ein neuer krieg wir
beschäftigen uns mit der krise im nahen
osten rund um iran irak und den konflikt
mit den usa und wir beginnen in iran
dort hat es bei den
trauerfeierlichkeiten für den von den
usa getöteten iranischen general
soleimani eine massenpanik gegeben
mindestens 50 menschen sind dabei zu
tode gekommen über 200 wurden verletzt
hunderttausende waren durch die stadt
gezogen dicht gedrängt um den sarg des
toten den viele dort für einen märtyrer
halten als leiten dazu von jörg brase
seine heimatstadt kehrmann empfing den
sagt general solle man es mit einem
gewaltigen aufmarsch an trauergästen
auch hier wie an den tagen zuvor drängen
sich zehntausende um abschied zu nehmen
dem neuen nationalen märtyrer nahe zu
sein und dann passiert es eine
massenpanik bricht aus zahlreiche
menschen werden totgetrampelt oder
verletzt der leiter des nationalen
rettungsdienstes muss stündlich die
opferzahlen im staatsfernsehen nach oben
korrigieren
am morgen hatte irans parlament ein
erneutes wütendes vergeltungs signal
richtung usa gesendet
es verabschiedete mehrere neue anti
terror gesetze die ermordung solle man
es gilt nun als ein akt amerikanischen
staats terrorismus und rechtfertigt
gegenmaßnahmen wir haben nun auch das
verteidigungsministerium als terror
organisation anerkannt
außerdem alle die an befehl generals
alemany zu töten beteiligt waren
damit sind der verteidigungsminister und
präsident trump terroristen und müssen
bestraft werden ist diese entscheidung
eher symbolisch hat eine andere durchaus
praktischen nutzen
außerdem verabschiedete das parlament
einen sonder etat in höhe von 200
millionen euro für die revolutionsgarden
unter anderem für die geplanten
vergeltungsschläge gegen die amerikaner
hätte das von sanktionen gebeutelte volk
sonst gegen noch mehr geld fürs militär
protestiert hofft irans führung nun
offenbar dass diese entscheidung im zuge
des nationalen ausnahmezustands
hingenommen wird
die beerdigung soll in mannis wurde
wegen des tragischen zwischenfalls auf
den abend verschoben und mit unserem
korrespondenten vor ort in teheran mit
jörg brase nämlich sprechen wir jetzt
nochmal ihrer guten abends inwiefern
haben die tragischen ereignisse von
heute der tod nochmal vieler menschen
die stimmung im land noch mal
beeinflusst also ich bin heute ein paar
mal gefragt worden ob die toten von
kerner nun politisch instrumentalisiert
werden könnten indem die regierung da
noch weitere opfer vorführt die man dann
den amerikanern anlasten kann aber genau
das ist eben nicht passiert es ist nicht
so als ob das ereignis jetzt runter
gespielt oder verschwiegen wird nein das
staatsfernsehen berichtet darüber in der
form
das ist schon die opferzahlen durch gibt
aber man sieht keine bilder
die bilder der toten werden im
staatsfernsehen nicht gezeigt und ich
denke auch dass es einfach nicht in
diese inszenierung passt die wir da
jetzt in den vergangenen tagen und auch
heute erlebt haben es geht darum
natürlich einen neuen märtyrer zu
kreieren das volk in der trauer in der
wut über seinen tod irgendwie zu
vereinen und ja letztlich wahrscheinlich
auch vorzubereiten auf einen krieg bzw
auf eine militärische auseinandersetzung
mit den usa bleiben wir mal bei der
einigkeit der bevölkerung wenn man diese
bilder sieht diese hunderttausende auf
den straßen dann stellt sich ja schon
die frage wie echt ist das alles vor
nicht wenigen tagen von nicht wenigen
wochen hat es große proteste gegeben
also ist das inszeniert oder ist es
tatsächlich so dass die jüngsten
ereignisse das land zusammen bringen
also da ist natürlich ein großer teil
inszenierung dabei die viele der
menschen die man auf den straßen gesehen
hat die tragen plakate die zu tausenden
gedruckt wurden wo dann auch harte rache
angedroht wird auf diesen plakaten
da ist natürlich sehr viel inszenierung
dabei da wurden auch sehr viele menschen
mit bus transporten an die jeweiligen
orte gebracht um eben sicherzustellen
dass da wirklich beeindruckende bilder
entstehen aber wir haben das gestern in
teheran selbst erlebt und man hat es
heute auch noch mal gesehen
doch wie das staatsfernsehen das
inszeniert das ist einfach beeindruckend
da sind diese leute sind zum großen teil
freiwillig da und es gibt auch viele mit
denen wir gesprochen haben
die durchaus kritisch sind dem system
dem regime gegenüber die uns sagen dass
sie zum einen auch diesen general
durchaus geschätzt haben was viele gut
fanden ist dass er es doch geschafft hat
gegen den islamischen staat erfolgreich
ein
verteidigungs netzwerk aufzubauen und zu
verhindern dass de es eben in den iran
hineinwirken kann und es sind auch viele
dabei die sagen das ist schon etwas
anderes was da jetzt passiert ist da
sind die usa zu weit gegangen
die tötung von celemony das war auch ein
angriff auf uns die fühlen sich dadurch
persönlich gedemütigt das heißt da gibt
es schon eine einigkeit will ich nicht
sagen aber eine eine gemeinsame
betroffenheit die die leute auf die
straße bringt und in der trauer und in
der wut über seinen tod vereint und
natürlich gibt es immer noch viele im
iran die überhaupt nicht einverstanden
sind mit der politik des regimes auch
mit der richtung ließ sich das hier
entwickelt und die auch vielleicht den
general solle man nicht geschätzt haben
aber und sie hatten die an ereignisse
vor ein paar wochen angesprochen
diese ereignisse sind natürlich noch im
gedächtnis das heißt diese leute trauen
sich einfach gar nicht raus und trauen
sich jetzt nicht nur ihre kritik zu
äußern
denn die bekommen ja auch mit dass die
nationen hier im moment in eine ganz
andere richtung marschiert die große
frage ist natürlich wie geht es jetzt
weiter alle zeichen so scheint es
zumindest stehen im moment auf
eskalation was glauben sie wie wird sich
die führung in teheran jetzt
positionieren was ich da gibt es nur
zwei seiten die eine seite ist jetzt
wirklich diese vorbereitung auf den
gegenschlag der sicherlich kommen wird
was man jetzt gesehen hat ist dass sich
dieses netzwerk das general zeremonie in
den letzten jahren geknüpft hat von in
der region aufgestellten schiitischen
milizen dass die sich jetzt nach seinem
tod ganz offen versuchen
zusammen zu schließen da soll es
koordinierungstreffen geben bei denen
sich diese gruppen dann absprechen
wollen und gemeinsam in den kampf gegen
die usa ziehen das ist die eine
geschichte die andere geschichte ist ja
ich hatte es im beitrag angesprochen
diese 200 millionen euro die jetzt aus
den staats rücklagen zur verfügung
gestellt werden um diesen kampf zu
finanzieren das ist also auf der einen
seite die vorbereitung auf die
militärische auseinandersetzung
andererseits sehen wir aber auch dass
das iranische regime sich immer noch
eine tür offen halten will
für verhandlungen über das atomprogramm
an immer noch einen spalt weit die tür
auf um dann letztlich mit den
unterzeichnerstaaten also auch mit den
europäern zu reden und eventuell dann
auch mit den amerikanern sich wieder an
einen tisch zu setzen
informationen und einschätzungen waren
das von jörg brase in teheran live
vielen dank für dieses gespräch
die ereignisse im iran beziehungsweise
ihnen ihre an beschäftigen natürlich
auch die deutsch iraner bei uns das sind
immerhin mehr als 230.000 und wir haben
zwei von ihnen getroffen und sie mal
nach ihrer meinung zu den jüngsten
entwicklungen gefragt aus einer
persönlichen perspektive und warte aus
beobachtet das window unruhig das
betrifft meinen alltag und beunruhigt
mich dem alltag ich arbeite aber
parallel verfolge ich die entwicklung
und hoffen wir mal das beste für die
iranische bevölkerung transaktion hat es
geschafft dass die bevölkerung jetzt
emotionalisiert ist teilweise wieder auf
die strafen geht tatsächlich was ja
lange nicht gemacht haben überhaupt um
pro regierungen kundgebungen zu besuchen
es wurden viele bestimmt auch bezahlt
die auf die straße kommen sollen es mit
sicherheit nicht die mehrheit der
bevölkerung das eine absolute minderheit
der bevölkerung die auf die straße
gegangen ist mit dem land iran tief
verwurzelt sie leben lieben das land
haben sehr viele erinnerungen an dem
laden viele sind nie wieder hingereist
und diese erinnerung ist sehr stark in
denen deswegen kritisieren alle glaube
ich auch gemeinschaftlich egal aus
welchem lager sie kommen auch die aktion
von fan hoffe dass
der iran irgendwann oder die heimische
bevölkerung der iran irgendwann zu einer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
[Musik]
kommen so wie sie hier auch genießen
können als deutsch iraner oder deutsche
und dass wir zu einem positiven
prosperierenden zusammenarbeit aller
länder kommen so wie man sich das für
jeden jedes volk vorstellt also lasst
uns gemeinsam leben lasst uns gemeinsam
achten und friedlich zusammenleben
soweit also zwei stimmen aus deutschland
wir vertiefen das thema weiter mit
antwort politikwissenschaftlerin an der
tu chemnitz guten abend vorne zollt wir
haben jetzt schon viel über die
aktuellen ereignisse gesprochen wenn wir
jetzt noch mal schritt zurückgehen das
ganze nochmal aus einer etwas größeren
perspektive betrachten wo liegen denn
eigentlich genau die ursachen für den
konflikt insbesondere zwischen den usa
und iran und die ursachen des konflikts
gehen bis ins jahr 1979 zurück als die
islamische revolution den von den usa
unterstützten scharia stürzte im
anschluss sieht sich die islamische der
islamische staat auch als vertreter der
schiiten also einer grundrichtung des
islam und hat auch ein gewisses
sendungsbewusstsein als führer der
schiiten in die an in die region hinaus
unterstützt quasi andere kräfte in
anderen ländern in im libanon in syrien
in den golfstaaten so dass es hier immer
wieder zu konflikten kommt darüber
hinaus hat sich das ganze zugespitzt mit
dem sogenannten atomkonflikt seit 2002
hier geht es darum dass der iran
nuklearwaffen relevante fähigkeiten und
kapazitäten erworben hat und da kam es
eben zu dem konflikt mit der
internationalen gemeinschaft dass man
eben hier dem iran zurückbringen wollte
präsident tram hat dieses joint
comprehensive plan auf action also
dieses abkommen die saturn abkommen mit
dem iran dann schließlich im jahr 2000
also letztes jahr wieder vorletztes jahr
muss man jetzt sagen wieder aufgekündigt
nun wird sich der konflikt daneben in
den letzten zwei jahren noch mal massiv
verschärft hat eben auch da würde ich
gerne noch mal einen haken inwieweit hat
sich die krise dann durch das
aufkündigen des abkommens durch die usa
verschärft nun die dem iran wurde im
gegenzug für seine einschränkungen des
nuklearprogramms der iran hat auch
verschiedene ihm eigentlich auch
zustehende fähigkeiten und kapazitäten
verzichtet also geringere
urananreicherung gerade mengen von
zentrifugen die benutzt werden
verschiedene technologien im gegenzug
wurden ihm eben das auf können also die
das aufheben der sanktionen die für das
mit dem und claire programm in
verbindung standen zugesagt dass eben
die wirtschaft die iranische wirtschaft
die auch damals schon am boden lag eben
wieder neue initiative bekommt sich
entwickeln kann
das hat alles nicht so wirklich gut
funktioniert weil eben verschiedene
andere sanktionen die eben nicht mit dem
nuklearprogramm in verbindung standen
sondern mit anderen eben aktionen des
iran in der region nicht auf gekündigt
wurden so dass eben die wirtschaft dass
iran sich nicht wirklich entwickeln
konnte
das hat eben dazu geführt dass der iran
mit dem aufkündigen des abkommens gesagt
hat seine seite ist eigentlich für die
internationale atomenergieagentur hat
ihm auch immer wieder bescheinigt es
hält sich da iran hält sich an seine
auflagen
er sieht jetzt die usa ist die in
die dass die sich nicht an ihre abkommen
an das abkommen gehalten haben indem sie
eben ausgetreten sind und eben ihre
seite nicht erfüllt haben daran
da hab ich gerade noch mal einen haken
wie reagieren hat man eben ja die usa
haben das abkommen aufgekündigt das
hatten sie gesagt der iran hat ja
inzwischen selber auch gesagt dass er
sich nicht weiter an das abkommen
gebunden fühlt ist damit dieser deal
erledigt ich wäre zu sagen also
eigentlich wäre könnte man sagen wäre er
schon erledigten dem moment wo die us
ein aufkündigen denn die europäer in
zusammenarbeit mit den chinesen russen
haben russland hat versucht dieses
abkommen zu retten indem man eben
versucht hat das zu kompensieren was die
die die sanktionen die die usa eben
wieder aufgesetzt haben was natürlich
schwierig ist weil ein großteil des geld
des welthandels eben in dollar
abgewickelt wird und die usa eben auch
gedroht haben das unternehmen die mit
den dem mit dem iran geschäfte machen
dann eben in den usa sanktioniert werden
oder deren amerika geschäfts
sanktioniert wird
und nun stehen verschiedene firmen vor
der abwägung machen sie mehr umsätze
mehr geschäfte in den usa oder im iran
und das hat eben dazu geführt dass eben
man das abkommen auch von europäischer
seite trotz verschiedenster bemühungen
politischer bemühungen in dem sinne
nicht retten konnte also man konnte das
nicht kompensieren dass die usa ihr
ausgestiegen sind und wenn die usa aus
so lange zeit trotzdem noch daran ja
also die usa die sind ja ausgestiegen
das ist klar aber wenn jetzt im prinzip
alle anderen dann auch mitmachen also
aus dem westen im prinzip auch nicht
weiter an diesem deal mit iran
festhalten können was bedeutet das dann
für die zukunft in der region wenn es
dieses abkommen dann so nicht mehr gibt
das könnte sehr gefährlich für die
zukunft werden denn der iran hat er
jetzt schon wieder verschiedene
fähigkeiten aufgenommen erreicht sein
uran wieder höher an
dazu muss man wissen je höher das uran
angereichert ist umso eher ist es
waffenfähig iran ist wieder bei einer 20
prozentigen anreicherung das ist quasi
90 des weges zu waffenfähigem uran
es hat verschiedene
forschungsaktivitäten wieder aufgenommen
es hat
die menge an zentrifugen auch neue
zentrifugen technologien wieder
aufgenommen was eben dazu führen kann
dass es eben die der zeitraum den iran
braucht um quasi die nuklearwaffen zu
bauen die bombe zu bauen
er verringert sich wieder dadurch
könnten sich andere mächte in der region
vor allen dingen saudi arabien ja
gedrängt fühlen jetzt ihrerseits auch
wieder den eventuellen nuklearwaffe
erwerben zu wollen oder aufbauen zu
wollen
denn da kommt wieder dieser dieser
konflikt zwischen schiiten und sunniten
hinein
der iran der daneben als schiitische
macht in der region eine nuklearwaffe
hätte was sich die sunniten im gegenzug
natürlich nicht bieten lassen wollen die
wollten dann nachziehen ihrer saudi
arabia hat er mehrfach angekündigt es
würde keine iranische nuklearwaffe
dollar also diese virale beziehungsweise
rüstungsspirale könnte sich dadurch
weiter drehen jetzt ist ja auch die
informationen inzwischen da dass die
deutschen soldaten aus dem irak
abgezogen werden beziehungsweise das
ganze läuft schon auch aus anderen
nato-staaten was bedeutet das für die
region
das hat in dem sind erstmal keinen
direkten einfluss auf den konflikt
zwischen dem iran und den usa sie wenn
er aus sicherheitspolitischen erwägungen
abgezogen
falls es eben dazu dem konflikt kommen
könnte natürlich sehr schnell dem irak
mit auffassen würde der irak der ja die
schiitische regierung des irak die sehr
stark mit dem iran verbunden ist das
schwächt allerdings den kampf gegen den
den es gegen den islamischen staat denn
die die nato-truppen auch die deutschen
truppen
deutsche soldaten sind in ausbildungs
missionen da um den kampf gegen den
islamischen staat zu unterstützen
das heißt es können die jetzt dazu
führen dass der islamische staat wieder
stärker wird bzw
der kampf gegen islamische staat der ja
auch noch lange nicht gewonnen ist dass
der jetzt wieder erhebliche rückschritte
nimmt letzte frage sehen sie denn auch
die chance für eine deeskalation der
lage bzw was müsste denn jetzt dafür
passieren
als die chance wenn der deeskalation
sehe ich auf jeden fall denn weder die
usa noch der iran ist wirklich an einem
konflikt einem ausbruch eines krieges
gelegen
das hat man auch daran gesehen da iran
hat jetzt noch nicht reagiert das ist
einige tage vergangen
man hat zwar die massen also auch die
die straße die man befriedigen muss es
wird irgendeine art der vergeltung geben
müssen des irans die frage ist hier wie
man wie man reagiert also wir sehen ja
schon seit einigen monaten dieses spiel
da gegenseitigen provokationen
es besteht natürlich immer die die
gefahr dass es eskalieren kann aber
letzten endes ist weder den usa noch dem
iran an den wirklichen krieg also an dem
militärischen direkten
auseinandersetzung der beiden gelegen
also beides sind glaube ich nicht daran
interessiert dass es dazu kommt ja ihre
worte in den ohren aller
konfliktparteien vielen dank an die
netzwelt war das von der tu chemnitz
politikwissenschaftlerin danke ihnen für
das gespräch
soweit unser live stream zur krise in
iran wir bedanken uns bei euch für die
aufmerksamkeit wünschen euch noch einen
schönen abend und sagen bis bald
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch dieses thema hier an
leistung von uns über die kurden in
syrien krieg oder diese hier
ob wir nämlich mit hightech das klima
retten können oder ihr guckt euch das an
das ist nämlich der zdf- heute- kanal
den könnte ja abonnieren und dann
verpasste in zukunft überhaupt keinen
livestream bzw andere interessante
inhalte von uns mehr das würde uns
natürlich am allermeisten freuen
[Musik]